[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: I love the
first person that clapped.
Where are you?
High five.
A round of applause
for this man up here.
Started the clap
for the presenter.
I like it.
Hey, everybody.
Welcome to day three
of Google I/O. Yeah?
We feeling it?
Everyone properly
caffeinated today?
No?
OK.
Good.
Good to know where we're
starting off as a team
here all together.
So I've got to tell
you, when we actually
got this talk agreed
upon, they came to me
and they said, all
right, you know,
we love the title of your talk,
GCP on a Shoestring Budget,
we love the narrative that
you're trying to bring,
helping developers
save on money.
When do you want
to give the talk?
And I had one answer.
I said, day three.
8:30 in the morning.
No other possible
opportunity there.
And you want to know why?
Because the people
who are willing to go
through two days of standing
in the sun and wake up at 6:00
AM to stay in the security line
to get in the seats by 8:30,
they care about saving money on
Google Cloud Platform, right?
Yeah, exactly.
So thank you for being here.
Now when we get a chance to
talk to a lot of developers
around the world, I find
that there's generally
two buckets of people, or
two buckets of companies
that companies fall
into when you're
talking about saving costs.
The first one is
your large companies
with established codebases.
They may have expected workloads
that come through Google Cloud,
but the predominant
conversations we have are,
hey, you know if you make
this change and this change,
you can save a lot of money.
And their response is always
along the lines of, well,
how much would that
cost to implement?
We've got this legacy codebase.
You know, bill over here
really is attached to that API.
We really don't want
to get rid of that.
Basically any conversations we
have with these individuals,
they always have an
opportunity/cost trade-off
that they have to
make in their head
before they're willing
to actually make
the changes to save the money.
Right?
On the other side,
though, are the hustlers.
The rise and grind, right?
The startups.
The people living customer
to customer every single day,
trying to get those
costs as low as possible
because they know that
that's the key to keeping
their business afloat right now.
And those are the
people hopefully
that wake up so early,
after two days of sunscreen
and dehydration, to come
to this sort of talk.
And that's who we're
talking about today.
All right.
Now Google Cloud
Platform is huge.
We have a ton of
different products,
and quite frankly, the
40 minutes that they've
given me here, we
don't have enough time
to go through all of them.
So today we're going to
focus on three main things.
Number one, we're going to lay
some foundation on the network
and show you how to save
a little bit of costs
there, just to kind
of ease everyone
into what we're talking about.
Then we're going to
talk about some ways
to save costs on compute.
And then we're going to go
through a couple of scenarios
that hopefully some
of you fall into
and you'll have a little
bit better time attaching
to your business model.
But the most important
thing you need to know
is that nothing I'm talking
about today is secret.
None of this requires a
handshake or the right Google
badge to get this
information about how
to optimize this stuff.
Every piece of data
you're seeing today
is available for you to go
get right now, either using
the Google Cloud Platform
pricing calculator,
or looking at the pricing pages
for the individual products.
Like this is it.
Again, it's not an
Illuminati style thing here.
You can go run the same
analysis on everything
you're doing on your own.
So let's get started.
Serving data.
This is where we're
going to start today.
Let's figure out
what does it cost
to serve one terabyte of
data from Google Cloud
Storage to your users.
Just bare minimum
discussion here.
Let's just talk
about serving data.
Now when you think
about this, you
have two components involved.
First off is storage--
where you're storing your data--
and second off is
your network costs
for actually
transferring the data.
Now the costs for these
are dependent upon usage.
So for example, Google
Cloud Storage, what you pay
is a function of
where you're hosting
your data alongside of
how much you're hosting.
So for example, if you're
actually hosting your data
in US central one region, you're
paying about $0.02 per gig
to actually store your data.
However, you move to
US East, that changes.
And if using a
multi-region bucket,
then that changes as well.
On the networking side, it's
a tiered cost structure.
So if you're under one terabyte,
you pay a different price
than if you're in the next
tier of one terabyte to 10
terabytes, and 10 terabytes up.
And then this also changes
per region as well.
So for example, if
you're transferring data
from the Iowa location,
which is US central one,
and you're in the first
tier of under one terabyte,
you're paying about $0.12 a gig.
Now with this in mind,
though, we have to point out
something-- and again,
this is not secret,
this is widely known--
is that there's a whole tier
of usage on Google Cloud that's
absolutely free that you get
every single month that you
can just use this stuff.
No one cares about it.
You're not going to
get charged for it.
And it ranges from mostly
all of our products.
But most specifically
for our case right now,
we're worried about,
what is the free tier
for network and storage?
On the storage side, we
actually get five gigabytes
of storage for free
each month, each region.
So if you've got five gigs in US
East and give gigs in US West,
each one of those is free.
On the network side, we
get about one gigabyte
of egress, which
is outbound data
traffic, from North
American locations
to other destinations.
And by the way, you will see
many caveats of little stars
during this, and you'll also
see a lot of little labels that
says, the price of today.
This is the Cloud.
Prices change.
And if you discover this
video in the future,
you will undoubtedly
find that there's
a discrepancy in the prices.
So please make
sure you check out
the documentation
for the latest.
So this is our free tier.
Let's talk about
egress cost then.
So one terabytes of data
that we want to send.
So what would this cost us?
So to store it, we get
about one terabyte of data
storing in US central one.
That's 1024 gigs, minus our five
gig free tier at $0.02 per gig.
About $20 a month.
Just to store the data at rest.
Not too bad.
On the network
side, though, things
get a little bit trickier.
So we've got our one
terabyte of data,
minus the gig in the free
tier at $0.12 per gig.
About $122 a month for
a total of about $143.
So storing the
data, transferring
a terabyte of data, about $143.
Which isn't too
bad I don't think.
But the truth is
that most of you
actually don't send
your users directly
to your Cloud storage bucket.
Chances are you have
some proxy, some
front-end that
they're hitting first
if you're website or something
else that this data is
being routed through.
So let's take a look
at what that costs.
Basically the same.
So as long as you're
transferring information
in the same region
between a Cloud storage
bucket and a Compute
Engine instance, it's free.
You don't have to worry
about that as long as it's
in the same region.
And then your egress
rates are still the same
if they're coming from Compute
Engine or from Cloud storage.
So basically, if you're
transferring all your data
through a proxy, you're
paying the same exact price
as you would if it was going
from Cloud storage directly.
The only difference is that
you're now actually paying
for the Compute Engine
instance running there,
or the Cloud function's instance
or the app engine instance.
So basically, as long
as you're using proxy,
the basic serving
costs don't change.
But let's look at this
from a different way.
When we serve data
to people, especially
through Cloud storage, one
of the things we care about
is locality and latency.
So we want to get our data as
close to our users as possible,
but we also want to do it
as cheaply as possible.
So let's take a look
at that scenario.
So let's say we're
serving our data here,
we've got it in US
West one, and we
want to serve it to a
user in US East one.
So we're going across
the continental US.
Price here is still
the same, $143.
It doesn't matter where
the user is coming from,
we still have the same cost at
rest and the same egress costs.
But we want to get that
data closer to the user.
So what if we actually cloned
that data in US East one
and got it closer to the user?
Well of course at this point,
our egress is still $0.12.
No change there.
And Cloud storage
itself, we're now
duplicating the data between
two buckets so of course
we're paying that extra
$0.02 a gig to copy it
into this other
location, so we're
doubling our cost for storage.
And we also have
this extra $0.01
per gig transfer
cost between them
because we're moving our
data between regions.
So now we actually have a cost
that's incurred with that.
So to actually clone this
data between regions,
we're actually looking at $173.
Not ideal, but it gets our
data a little bit closer.
But the truth is we
might be thinking
about this the wrong way.
So we do have these things
in Google Cloud Storage,
we have regional buckets
and multi-regional buckets.
And what multi-regional
buckets do
is effectively duplicate your
data between regions in an area
so that you don't have to
do this cloning by yourself.
The trick, though, is that
multi-regional buckets
cost a little bit more.
So take a look at that.
So if we want to go
from Cloud storage right
to our users, our egress
rate from a Cloud storage
multi-regional
bucket-- by the way,
there's going to be
lots of weird acronyms
and terminology in this talk.
It's labeled intermediate
so hopefully we're
all move in together--
$0.12 per gig egress.
However, we're
paying $0.026 per gig
to store in a multi-regional
bucket, which puts us
at about $26 a month
for that storage
instead of what we were
paying for the single region.
We're at about $149 there.
So not too much cost change.
But the difference here is
that when a user in US East one
actually asks for
this asset, Google
handles the
duplication of getting
that data closer to the
user on your behalf,
and you don't have
to clone it yourself.
So we basically just
saved an extra $30
by using a multi-regional
bucket per month
instead of actually
cloning it ourselves.
OK.
Sounds good.
So we've actually reduced our
cost inside the regional US.
But what if we want
to go international?
So we want to serve this data
to someone in Europe, right?
Well let's take a look
at cloning there as well.
So again, we have our clone data
in a US multi-region and an EU
multi-region, so obviously
we're duplicating our costs.
We have the same amount of cost
egress for the EU multi-region,
which is selected
for these numbers.
However, now because
we're transferring
data between multi regions
in different areas,
we're actually at
$0.12 per gig transfer.
So we actually get a
little bit pricier there.
$286 this is the result of this.
So if you're trying to
get your data to users
in a different area
using the multi-region,
it's actually really expensive.
But let's rethink this here.
So the goal-- again,
we're shoestring.
We want to make this
as cheap as possible.
We want to get data from the
cheapest bucket we can store it
in to the farthest
away user as fast as
possible, as cheap as possible.
We already have this.
It's called the CDN.
Right?
We've all been
working with these.
So let's figure out what
the cost is of that.
So we've got our standard
regional Cloud storage
in EU West at about $0.02 a gig.
Now for CDNs, there's two
costs you need to be aware of.
We have a fill cost
and an egress cost.
To fill data into the cache,
you're looking at about $0.04
per gig to get it into the CDN.
And that's worldwide.
It doesn't matter
where you're going.
So if you have data here
and someone in Nairobi
asks for your asset,
it's $0.04 per gig
to cache it to the
closest point of presence
that Google has there.
Now egress from the CDN
is only $0.08 per gig.
So when you combine these two
together, $0.04 and $0.08,
you actually end
up at about $0.12
per gig, which is your
standard outbound egress rate.
However, this is assuming
a one to one ratio.
So if you're actually
pushing a terabyte of fill
and serving that
same terabyte, you're
going to end up at about
$143 to get that asset as
close to every user in the world
without you lifting a finger,
except making sure your cache
headers are turned on properly.
But in reality, this isn't
how things work out, right?
Typically the amount of
cache fill versus cache
serve are quite different.
So if you're actually
in an 80-20 split
here where 20% of your data
is filled into the cache
and 80% is actually served
out, you actually only
end up closer to about $91.
So as long as that ratio is
on the serving side instead
of the filling
side, you're going
to have a lot cheaper
representation and set up.
You're going to get closer to
that shoestring value you want.
So in general here,
if we're looking
to serve a terabyte of
data, the cheapest thing
we can do to get it to
users across the world
as fast as possible is simply
to set your caching headers.
Any other tricks or
any other smartness
that you're trying to do
is going to blow that up.
It's going to make
things more expensive.
So find the cheapest bucket
that's as close to you
as you can tolerate,
put your data in that,
and then turn on
the CDN and like
Google's point of presence
network handle the rest of it.
All right, let's
talk about Compute.
So Google Cloud Platform has
a lot of Compute offerings,
but today we're only going
to talk about three of them.
First off is Google
Compute Engine,
which is our standard VMs
that run in the Cloud.
Second is, of course,
Google Cloud Functions,
which are our invocation
based Compute resources.
And third, of course, is Google
App Engine, which has both
managed and invocation based.
And for the sake
of this talk, I'm
going to ignore things like
Google Kubernetes Engine
and GAE Flex because
these actually
tend to price themselves
closer to what GCE is.
But for the sake of
this 40 minute talk,
we don't have to go
into all the nuances.
It's a little bit weird.
So I'm just going
to ignore those.
We're going to focus on these
three offerings right now.
So by cost, of course,
GCE is variable on config.
Depending on what configuration
you're using is how much
you're going to pay.
The beefier the
machine that you're
using in the configuration,
the more you're
going to have to pay there.
Cloud Functions, though,
it's a little bit different.
Cloud Functions is about $0.40
per million calls that you make
to it.
And then there's also
an additional cost
you have to be concerned with
is what we call gigabytes second
and gigahertz second.
And if you check out
the documentation,
there's a little bit--
a little bit better
breakdown here.
I'm not going to get a chance
to go through it today.
And of course, App Engine is
going to be $0.05 to $0.30 per
instance hour, depending
on your config.
So this is the default
cost that you have here.
Now on the other side, we
have our free tiers, though.
Now here's where
things get really cool.
In Compute Engine,
if you're using
an F1 micro configuration,
it's free the whole month.
No cost to you.
Free instance sitting in the
Cloud, doing your bidding,
as much as you'd
like it, all free.
On GCF, you got about two
million invocations a month,
or 400,000 gigabyte seconds
and 200,000 gigahertz seconds.
And on App Engine's, you
have 28 instance hours
a day for an F1 instance, and
about nine instance hours a day
for a B1 instance.
And I know there's not--
I know there's more than 20--
there's less than
28 hours in a day.
So that gives you a little
bit of wiggle room in case
your extra instance
spins up in an F1.
So basically here when you look
at GCE F1 micro and GAE F1,
you kind of get
free compute as long
as you're under a
certain strata of usage.
With this in mind, let's take
a look at an always-on cost.
So let's say you want to run a
box 24/7 for an entire month.
What does that cost you?
So months have different
days and we always have leap
year and stuff like that.
So I'm just going to assume 730
hours of consistent run time.
What we end up with if
we're using an F1-micro,
it's free the whole month.
Don't have to pay a thing.
However, when you bump
up to an N1-standard-1
because you want a little
bit more performance,
you start paying $24 a
month, and $194 a month
for an eight core machine.
This is all on the
Cloud pricing page.
You can see all of this.
And by the way, this is after
a 30% sustained usage discount,
which I'll get to in a second.
Cloud Functions,
though, we can't really
compare apples to apples.
Because it's an
invocation based system,
we can't just say,
consistently running.
So what I've done here is
I'm making the assumption
that you're getting one
invocation to your Cloud
Function service every
second for the entire month.
So you got about 2.6
million invocations a month
that's going on there.
That lets us kind
of simulate what
an always-on cost would be.
For this, it's about
$3.51 to basically
have a GCF function
running every second
for an entire month.
On App Engine, you end up,
of course, in the F1 config,
it's free.
Don't have to change
anything there.
However, if that second F1
instance actually spins up,
you get a little
spike in your workload
or all of a sudden
you're the top of hacker
news for some
reason, you're going
to pay $36 for that second
instance to come onboard.
Of course, when you move
up to an F2 or an F4, which
again, are beefier machines,
you get the $73 and the $146.
So basically across
the board here
you can see that in GCE and GAE,
as you get a stronger machine,
of course the costs go
up, while GCF is still
pretty instance based.
Now here's the
interesting thing.
So those are basic costs.
So obviously Compute Engine
is the most versatile thing
we have.
It can run whatever
code you want,
whatever instance you
want, your images,
and all this other stuff.
But the problem is it's
also the most expensive
for what you're using.
So it would be really cool
if we could figure out
how to make that as cost
effective as our other services
without having some of
the same limitations.
So for example, if we just
wanted to run our code on GCE,
we have problem which is that
each function invocation has
a nine minute timeout.
So you can't
actually get anything
for more than nine minutes.
On the other side,
on App Engine,
you have a 60 second
time out on requests,
but if you push
that off to a task,
later you're going to end
up with the same nine minute
timeout.
So our goal here
is to figure out
how to make GCE as cheap
as our other alternatives.
And the good news
is we can do this.
First off, let's take a
look at the GCE discounts.
Now these are the
things that you really
don't have to lift
any fingers to do
to actually turn this stuff on.
So first off is sustained use.
So what we'll do on Google Cloud
Platform is analyze your usage
and if you have a sustained
usage, so you're always
on for a certain
amount of time, we'll
give you a default
discount for just
running your instance
with consistency
across the entire month.
If you're willing to make a
phone call to our sales team
and can actually commit to
usage, specific usage, and say,
I'm going to run at least
2,000 hours this month,
or 730 hours this month.
You know, it doesn't matter
what configuration you're using
and you don't have
any pre-definition
of specific upfront
fees or whatever.
You can actually get
up to a 56% discount
by just making a phone
call to talk to sales.
So if you're a
startup and you're
starting to see a little
bit more usage and you need
that dedicated
resource and you know
you're going to have
one or two instances
running at a dedicated
fashion, making that phone call
and getting that 56% savings
is actually pretty huge.
And of course, right sizing.
So what will happen is
Google Cloud Platform
will actually analyze the
usage of your GCE instances
and look at how
you're using them
and actually tell
you whether or not
you're over provisioned
or under provisioned.
And you'll see a little icon
appear on the home page that
will say, hey, if
you click here,
we'll reconfigure this for you
and save you money every month.
Likewise it'll say, hey,
you're using this pretty hard.
If you click here, will
beef up your machine
so that your users
get lower latency.
So it's a fun little
button that you can just
click, the deployment
happens behind the scenes,
you don't have to do anything.
So this is kind of
automatic stuff.
However, something
that's a little bit more
drastic in terms of
saving that does require
a little bit of
work on your part
is something called preemptive.
Now what preemptive
VMs are means
that the scheduler is allowed to
kill your instance when we need
the resources in Google Cloud.
Now that may sound really
scary, but here's the fun part.
It will actually
alert your instance
before it's about to get killed.
So it'll send you a message and
your instance will say, hey,
I'm about to terminate you.
You've got roughly
about 30 seconds
to backup any data to
some persistent resource.
And then once it
kills your instance,
it'll start your
instance back up later
and then you can then
go fetch that data
and continue working on.
So if you allow us to kill your
instance when we need the time,
we actually give you a
substantial discount.
If you're running at an
N1-standard that's preemptive,
instead of paying
the $24 a month,
you get a 3x discount
down to about $7
a month for the same
instance, and all
you do is to have to write the
code so that you can lay over
those sorts of
terminations after time.
And the cool thing is that
you can actually put a load
balancer in front of that.
So if you need scalable
compute and you
need the ability to allow
these things to die,
but because you've got so
much load coming in, you know,
one of them going
down means another one
might have to spin up.
Putting a load balancer in front
of your preemptive instances,
since load balancing
is free, again,
means you're only paying
about $7 a month per instance
that you're actually running.
Of course, we can get this a
little bit cheaper, in fact,
if we actually use a micro
instance there instead.
We can actually get it down
to $2.96 per month using
an F1-micro, but because of
the fact that we have our load
balancer and because of the
fact that we've re-engineered
our code to make sure that it
can be fault tolerant when it's
killed, we actually have a
massively scalable compute
resource that can handle
itself getting kicked over.
So if you've got large
amounts of workloads
or individual things,
you're processing
lots of individual files
where something can pick up
processing 50% where
something else left off,
this is an extremely
cheap solution for you.
Probably as cheap
as I was actually
able to find in my research.
So in general, if you to
reduce your compute costs,
you got a couple of
things you need to do.
First off is
distribute workloads
that are based on invocations
to either App Engine or Cloud
Functions.
Those are going to be the
cheapest situations where
you can put your code
and have them run.
If you need something
long running,
then leave it back
on Compute Engine,
but otherwise try to
push as much as you can
to those resources.
That's going to be the
cheapest you can get.
Likewise, make sure
that you're making
that phone call to sales.
Let them know that
you're willing to commit
to a sustained use and get
that discount, because that's
going to be huge for them
work jobs that you actually
need running consistently
on Compute Engine.
And likewise, if you
have scalable needs,
a load balancer plus a
micro preemptive instance
is pretty much the highest
flexibility, lowest cost
scenario you can be in.
Having a bunch of little
spiders doing your work for you
at scale is just as effective
as having one behemoth doing it
for a higher price.
All right.
So those are our
basics here, so we've
kind of laid the
groundwork for how
we're going to
evaluate these things
and look at the big picture
between network and compute.
Now let's talk about
some scenarios.
Personal privacy
matters online, right?
We all kind of care about that,
especially when we're logging
into public WI-FI and whatnot.
But sometimes I don't
like paying a subscription
to some other service
to handle a VPN service.
So how cheap can we build
our own personal VPN service
on Google Cloud?
Now to be clear here, I know
that personal security online
is a very hectic area
right now, and there's
lots of back and forth.
So to be very clear, I'm
not going to talk today
about why you need a VPN.
I'm not going to debate
the different software
libraries you can use
or having your own VPN
versus being part of a cluster.
I'm basically not going to talk
about anything that PR or legal
would raise an eyebrow about.
But I am going to
talk about how you
can run your own VPN on Google
Cloud for as cheap as possible.
All right?
So with this, we have
two components, Compute
and Network.
Pretty easy.
How a VPN generally works is you
have your client that connects
to some Compute Engine instance
that's running your VPN,
there's a socket
connection between the two
that are exchanging
encrypted data,
and then the Compute Engine
instance or the proxy
will actually go out into
the fantastic internet
and do all your
fetching for you,
return that data back
to your computer.
This is a high
level approximation.
If there's any security
engineers in the room,
I apologize for
generalizing that to a point
that I can fit on a slide.
So let's look at the free tier.
Here how cheap
could we make this?
Well if we use our
instance as an F1-micro,
then we know we can
get that for free.
And as long as our usage
is about less than one gig,
we know that we can
basically get that for free
as well, right?
So if we're using an
F1-micro and our usage
is less than one
gig, we can get a VPN
that we can use whenever we
want for free every single month
using Google Cloud Platform.
And you only start to pay when
you go over that free gig.
So if you're just using this
to log on to Wi-Fi hotspots
when you're traveling
around the world,
you basically get this
entire thing for free.
No big deal.
But here's one of
the problems is
that if you're using a
preemptive version of that,
you have a problem that you need
to know where to connect to.
And every time you reboot
that VM, you have a new IP.
Good news is on
Google Cloud Platform,
you can actually reserve
a static IP address,
and as long as it's assigned and
being used, it's free for you.
So you can go in, create
your instance, let it run,
get a static reserved
IP address that you
can use from your
personal devices that
stick around waiting for you,
and you don't pay anything.
So again, we can
run a personal VPN
with a static IP for
nothing each month.
And again, if you eclipse
the one gig free tier,
that's when you
actually start paying.
Let's talk about two
specific scenarios here.
What if you want
better bandwidth?
So what if you're
traveling and you actually
want this VPN because
you need to stream
some video from some
different location, right?
Well the important thing
you need to understand
is that the throughput
for a GCE instance
changes based upon
the core count.
It's actually capped
at the core count.
So the more cores you have-- you
can see here that on the side
there, we're at our
64 and 32 cores--
the more cores you have, the
higher your TCP throughput.
And this is where
a lot of people
get caught up when
they're trying
to increase their
bandwidth for their VPNs,
because you'll
notice that moving up
from the F1-micro, the next
available option is F1-small.
Which you would want to
use because that's going
to be one of the cheapest.
However you notice because
the number of core count
is the same, we actually
don't get any better bandwidth
by moving to there, even
though it's only $14 a month.
Moving on to the next one.
The actual first stage
you get where you actually
get some bandwidth increase
is actually the N1-standard.
So unfortunately, if
you're moving up and trying
to get better bandwidth,
to even get it there,
you have to start paying $24
a month for your VPN instance.
Unless of course it's
preemptive, in which case
you get it down to $7
a month, but then you
have to deal with
what happens when
you're in the
middle of a session
and your VPN decides to die.
So let's talk about
something I deal with a lot.
Traveling.
So a lot of us are
international nomads.
We spend a lot of time traveling
around, going to conferences,
talking to customers
and whatnot.
It'd be really nice if
we had our VPN follow us
because if we boot up a
VPN and US central one
and yet we're in
Malaysia, we don't want
to wait for our packet to
go all the way to the US
and then come back to us
because that's just going
to make our experience bad.
So I actually put together
a little hack for this
that I wanted to
share with everybody.
So it turns out that
you can actually
run the Google Compute
Engine APIs from Google Cloud
Functions.
So I actually wrote
a little web location
that I host that when I
load it while I'm traveling,
it'll figure out
what my location is,
and in Google Cloud
Functions, it'll
figure out what
the closest zone is
that I can run an F1-instance.
It'll kill whatever the
previous VPN instance I have is
and actually create a brand
new instance as close to me
as possible.
So as I'm traveling,
I can basically
just click a single
button, kill the old VM,
and create the new
VM as close to me
as possible, no matter
where I am in the world.
Again, for free,
because then I'm
not doing more than
two million invocations
of Cloud Functions per month.
So this is really nice.
So if you want to get the people
in your family using your VPN
and maybe charge
them $10 a month,
this might be a nice little
racket to play at Thanksgiving.
All right.
So let's talk about something
a little bit closer to home
for a lot of you,
is WordPress site.
Anyone WordPress
experts in here?
Couple people.
Still no caffeine in the house.
I like that.
We're closer to 9:00 AM now
and everyone's still sleeping.
This is good.
So WordPress is a large
and unwieldy beast, right?
There's lots of different
components involved and lots
of different ways
you can take this.
So when you actually Google
for WordPress Google Cloud
Platform, the first thing
you're actually introduced to
is a page for our
Google Cloud Launcher
with all of these pre-configured
operations that allow you
to one click deploy a WordPress
instance to your Google Cloud
account and just get
up and start moving.
So you can click any
of these and they
have a bunch of
different configurations
of how you want it all set up.
However, the default
setup for this
is actually less than ideal
from an expense perspective.
So these are all going to be set
up with an N1-standard-1, which
is $24 a month.
And of course, you're still
paying that $0.12 outbound
egress from there.
So this is putting us in
something we've seen before.
But let's talk about
complexity here.
So what if you're using
the simplest WordPress
site possible?
Well obviously you don't
need-- and you're only
using a single instance, right?
Because you don't
have that number--
that many number of users.
Well, you can actually use
the F1-micro for this instead,
which is free per month.
And again, if you're under one
gigabyte of outbound egress,
you can actually get
that for free as well.
So if you're a brand new
startup and your friends
are all like, hey, go sign up
for this website over here,
it's $10 a month to host
your WordPress site.
And you're still live in on
ramen out of the VC incubator
along with 40 other
people, this actually
saves you that $10 a
month to buy more ramen.
Yay.
But the question
that we have then
is the concept that we're
free as long as we're
under the free tier.
And this is something
I've been harping on
for a while is, what is the
cost before we eclipse that?
So if we assume that we've got
a network of one gigabyte free,
and our default WordPress site
that you deploy on App Engine
is about 272k per
visitor, it means
you can get roughly about 3,800
visitors a month before you
eclipse that bandwidth and
actually have to start paying.
And this is a really
important number for startups,
for the hustle and
flow type people.
Knowing how many
visitors you can actually
take before you have
to start paying money
and where you want to start
optimizing all of that data.
And of course, we could go into
a massive diatribe about how
to properly optimize your images
and compress your headers,
and serve all that data.
That's a different talk.
Right now we're just talking
about the fundamentals.
So right here we
basically say if we're
under roughly about
4,000 users a month,
we should be OK and
always in the free tier.
And of course, if you turn
on caching headers, that
will put things
going into the CDN
so it will increase this
number significantly
because the more users you
have that hit the same content,
it doesn't come out
of your main bucket,
it comes out of a
different bucket,
and you get a lot more users
to hit your information.
But what if you actually
end up on the top of hacker
news suddenly and you need
to start scaling up and down?
Well, the cool thing
here is that putting
the load balancer between the
CDN actually lets you do this.
You end up with the same
egress, $0.08 per gig outbound;
and the same fill,
$0.04 per gig fill.
And we can actually end
up with the F1-micro.
The problem now
we have though is
because we have a number
of instances instead
of a single one, you
need a persistent MySQL
instance for each of
your Compute instances
to be able to sync between.
Now unfortunately, as
of today I could not
find a way to get a free tier
setup with the SQL instance.
So that's going to be
around $29 a month.
So if you're above
that 4,000 user mark
and you're expecting
scaling, the minimum cost
you're going to end up
paying is around $29
just to make sure
that that Cloud SQL
instance is sitting around.
Or you could run it on your
own and N1-standard or F1-micro
and deal with all of the
provisioning and everything
else yourself.
Now it's worth noting
here that there's also
a plug-in for App Engine.
So if you're running
WordPress and you
want to run it on App Engine
instead of dealing with all
that other stuff,
you can actually
run it on an F1-micro instance--
or F1 instance on App Engine
and get that down to about
zero dollars a month.
Unfortunately, you still need
the SQL scalable back-end,
which runs on its own instance
at about $29 a month as well.
So something to think about.
In general, if you're doing
WordPress on Google Cloud
Platform, I got to
tell you there's
three strata you
need to think about
to make sure you're really
thinking about your shoestring
style budget.
If you're under 4,000 visitors,
just to use an F1-micro
and turn on the CDN
and you'll basically
get the whole thing for free.
Which is fantastic, right?
That's where we all want to be.
If you're above 4,000
visitors, then you
need to start thinking
about stringing together
Compute Engine plus
the load balancer,
plus the CDN, and
plus the SQL option;
or using App Engine
to do the same.
Because you have
enough users there
you need to start making
sure that you're doing things
properly.
However I got to
tell you that there
is a number of hosted
WordPress companies
that have their back-ends built
on Google Cloud Platform that
do offer you a
subscription based service.
So paying $4 a month, they'll
host your WordPress site,
they'll deal with
all the scalability,
they'll deal with all
the security updates,
they'll make sure everything
is running in the background.
You don't have to lift a finger.
And it might be a
cheaper option for you
to fall into that bucket if
you're above 4,000 visitors.
So that might be
something to look at too.
All right.
A final topic for the day.
Video content site on
a shoestring budget.
So with these things
in mind, we have
to look at what it would take
to make an education website
or like an online mook.
You have students
that log in, they
have some data they want to
look at they, watch some videos,
they take some tests.
You know, maybe you
have maybe a sports site
that's streaming all of your
high school sports games
and you got a lot of video
that you need to transfer.
But you have some combination
of rich multimedia
and rich website presence.
So with a standard
layout here, you
would probably have to store
that video data in Google Cloud
Storage and serve
that right to the user
so that you can get
streaming capability.
You don't want that
going through a proxy,
you want that coming
straight to the source there.
On the website
side, you probably
have an Apache instance or
maybe a WordPress instance
that is actually
hosting your website.
It's got some connection
to some relational database
so we can keep track
of who the users are,
what data they've seen, and any
other keywords that you need.
And then of course, you've got
your standard load balancing
and CDN in front of that so
you can scale up, scale down,
and make sure that your
data is consistently
sent to users around the world.
This gets pretty
pricey, unfortunately.
You're looking at $24 for the
Compute engines per instance
a month.
You're looking at $29 for
the Cloud SQL instance.
Of course you've got your
fill and your egress costs.
But where you really
get hit here of course
is serving that video.
Now as of today--
and again, this can change
in the future-- internet--
if you're watching this
sometime in the future.
As of today, the
Cloud CDN that's
coming from Google Cloud Storage
does not cache 206 responses
from an HTTP header.
206 responses are the ones that
are used for streaming video.
Which means as you're
streaming video,
it's not going
through the cache.
So we have to be very
cautious of this,
which means we're
going basically
into the $0.12 per gig ratio if
we're streaming data directly
from Google Cloud Storage.
Not really ideal.
This whole thing can
get pretty costly.
But there actually is
a solution if you're
willing to make a
couple of changes.
We can get it's almost down to
free instead of all this cost.
So first off, if you're
willing to make some changes,
leave your CDN in
place but instead
of actually using a dedicated
Compute Engine instance,
switch over your page serving
to be something invocation based
like Cloud Functions.
Minimize all of your crazy
complexity down to something
that he can use a template
for to just scrape
the data together,
put it together,
send it down in the HTTP
request as easy as possible.
Make it invocation based
so you don't really
need to do that much
in the back-end.
And as long as you're under
two million page views a month,
you can basically get that
entire serving process
for free.
Which is pretty nice.
Likewise, instead
of using Cloud SQL,
try to use Cloud Datastore
for your relational database.
If you're on a
shoestring budget,
Datastore will still
give you the performance
you need because most of
it is fetch based if you
are using a website like this.
And it has its own free tier.
If you're under one
gigabyte of stored data
and you're doing less than
500,000 reads and 100,000
writes per month, you
basically pay nothing.
Which I think is right in the
range of a MOOC-style startup
because you don't really have
all the visitors you need yet.
And even successful
ones are probably not
doing 500,000 or
100,000 per month.
And a gigabyte of
relational data
is actually a lot
in that scenario.
So we can basically get
our entire web site serving
and back-end storage
for about $0.
Now the problem,
though, is what do
we do about the video content?
Because there's no
real other place
to store this in Google
Cloud Storage because
of 206 responses.
My only solution here,
a little bit of a hack,
store all your video in YouTube.
Upload your video to YouTube,
leave it is unlisted,
and basically when you're
streaming your embedded URLs
down to your user, obfuscate
the hell out of your code
so they can't figure out
where the video URLs are.
If you can set it
up this way, you
get it entire content serving
and video production platform
for free.
A lot of chuckles, yes.
This slide is very
contentious internally.
We had a lot of talks--
we had a lot of talks
internally about
whether or not that
last little animation
should be in this talk at all.
So with that, I want to thank
you for your time today.
I want to thank you
for being the hustlers
and the grinders working on
your costs every single day.
I want to thank you for
waking up this early to hear
another bald man rant at you.
Most importantly, if
you care about cost,
if you care about
the performance
your Cloud applications,
I got to encourage
you to check out our YouTube
channel for Google Cloud
Platform.
We have a ton of amazing people
working on amazing content
to help you lower your costs,
increase your scalability,
and basically get your Cloud
application to where you
want it as cheap as possible.
With that, thank you.
Stay sunscreened, stay hydrated.
Enjoy your last day of Google
I/O. Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]